joining us now with more Fox News legal
analyst Greg Jarrett Fox News
contributor Sarah Carter and red State
Deputy managing editor Kira Davis let's
go to you first Sarah I mean you've been
at the border a lot we've all been
through this we would just listen you
know it's perplexed at how they're just
they're telling us that the moon is made
of green cheese and they just keep
saying it and but we won't we we are
refusing to believe that lie
um when we hear about the Fentanyl and
the cocaine it's not just about the
amount of money it's about it's killing
American citizens uh we know there was
an event down at the border where do
things stand what do you what do you
imagine uh coming up at this point
well this should absolutely be a
bipartisan issue Tammy and it is when
you talk to people along the border uh I
could say Democrat Henry Cuellar has
been very open about it it's been a huge
problem here in Texas I just returned
from Mexico City I was there with CPAC I
had the opportunity to visit two human
trafficking shelters this is where
they're keeping children who were being
trafficked towards the United States
where they had been rescued I can't even
begin to tell you children as young as
six years old to 18 years old both boys
and girls this is a humanitarian crisis
this is an issue that is a national
security crisis we've seen it at the
border think about this in October 86
000 known godaways in October those are
people that just got into our country in
one month and disappeared into the
fabric of America 230
000 Encounters this is more than we've
ever seen but really quickly before you
go on I this is what they want this is
the reason why President Biden and his
administration will not remove a failure
like mallorcus because in their eyes
he's not a failure he's doing exactly
what they wanted yeah it seems and Greg
to you on this it seems like they want
this you know they say this is the
mission uh then they lie and say they're
controlling the border and cleaning up
Trump's mess but at the same time they
say that they're looking to impeach
mayorkas what are your thoughts on the
the ability of them to actually pull
that off and is is what's happening now
is that really an impeachable offense at
this point
well an investigation is absolutely
merited impeachment probably is not
remember the Constitutional standard for
impeachment is high crimes and
misdemeanors 15 months ago Republicans
offered a resolution to impeach mayorkas
they issued this
13-page memo
justifying it I've read it it's
constitutionally and legally weak why
because disagreements over policy do not
rise to the level of impeachable
offenses stupidity and incompetence and
feckless policies are not high crimes
and misdemeanors the proper remedy is
not impeachment but rather a change at
The Ballot Box elections and just
because Nancy Pelosi and Democrats
abused and misused the impeachment
standard as a cudgel to bludgeon Donald
Trump whom they loathed into despise
doesn't mean Republicans should do the
same thing bad behavior doesn't give
license to others to engage in that same
bad behavior but there does need to be a
thorough investigation yes I haven't
seen uh their 13-page response and it
may in fact be weak but this is not just
about policy which doesn't exist by the
way but as you heard from Sarah this is
about uh in the incentives for human
trafficking it's about the drugs that
are coming in the fentanyl which can
kill pretty much now every American the
terrorists that have we know have gotten
over the Border we've caught some who
knows which ones we haven't caught so it
becomes a national security issue it
becomes a health care issue it becomes a
a Mexican cartel issue
aren't those things a little bit
different than policy disagreements
I I don't disagree with you entirely but
again it's not a high crime and
misdemeanor look a hundred thousand I
think that's Americans every year are
dying of synthetic opioids mostly
fentanyl coming across our Southern
border that's because of Joe Biden and
his horrible open borders policy that's
200 administered 73 Americans per day
right outraged over these mass shootings
10 15 20 people what about
273 people per day that's exactly my
point fentanyl Greg I agree and that's
and you know Cara as we we look at your
uh an editor you're involved in the
cultural Dynamic a commentary on
politics this is what can be confusing
for people is that this is causing the
deaths of Americans it is seems to be a
national security issue a crime issue a
health care issue uh care from Europe
really your perch uh how do you see this
when it comes to how we handle this
device chocolate at the border
well I I kind of agree with you Tammy I
I don't understand necessarily what the
definition of high crime or misdemeanor
is if this is a deliberate act I do
believe Democrats are leaving our board
borders wide open deliberately they know
what's going on at the border I mean if
even Katie Hobbs is saying hey we have a
border problem there are obviously
Democrats who live on the border and
experience the direct result of what's
going on plus we've seen them now have
to face them in places of all like God
forbid Martha's Vineyard and in Chicago
so they know what's going on and if
there is proof that they know how bad
things are and they're still leaving the
borders wide open is that not a high
crime people are dying because of what's
going on in our borders our nation is
dying because of what's going on at our
borders right now so I don't know I I'm
not the legal scholar here I'm just the
pretty face Tammy but if I had to you
know say well something is a high crime
yeah if you're leaving our border wide
open on purpose and you're watching
Americans succumb to the crime and
violence and drug epidemic that is just
walting across the border that sounds
like a high crime to me you know and I
think wrong for for you Kara uh
obviously no when dealing with kids in
schools and all of what we're dealing
with with the economy and with jobs and
with wages and with local crime and it's
just Sarah I'll give you the last word
on this when it comes to how how do we
we've got to stop this at some point
maybe it's about uh ending the funding
for what it is they're doing at the
border and instituting you know a
different kind of law framework via
action in the house
well absolutely absolutely but even more
than that and I'm just going to make
this quick look and I always agree with
Greg on mostly everything this time I'm
going to just have to disagree on this
because that border they know is wide
open we have children being poisoned in
our country they are not addicts they
are being poisoned by counterfeit pills
that are all over our streets we've lost
over a hundred and seven thousand
Americans the Chinese are our
adversaries the Chinese Communist party
is moving precursor chemicals in New
Mexico the Mexican cartels are moving it
into the United States they're
laundering the money back through China
back through China we are well aware of
what is happening at our border and when
it what is it going to take is it going
to take another 9 11 an attack on one of
our malls an attack on one of our cities
for us to say whoa a crime has just been
committed this is the federal government
do your job lock down the borders or the
Republican party is going to take you on
and end it Americans are tired of this
Greg thank you always the fair one but
hopefully we'll have some other
arguments when it comes to the nature of
what we can do thank you everyone hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else